You suggested that I call regarding my labs.
I just want to give you more information.
I lost a lot of blood during surgery in mid-April down to almost 7-7, meaning they're
healing a little bit, but I did not want to receive any blood.
Also I have a juicied and eating mostly vegetarian diet since then.
But just recently after labs started eating meat, do you still think I should send up a call?
Well, you don't need to.
If you feel like you're getting more energy, so hemoglobin down to 7 and not receiving any
blood, that's a big uphill battle that you have to climb, and it's doable.
But it's going to take time to build up your blood I'm talking about.
And it's more difficult to do on a vegetarian diet.
So while you're eating meat, you're going to help build your hemoglobin much quicker,
and have a better chance of doing that.
So no, we don't have to send up a call if you don't want to.
I would like to have you spend, if you're concerned about costs and such, and just get
another blood test.
So get regular blood tests.
If your doctor will do it, it'll cover under your insurance.
Get them done every week if you can.
Certainly, you're having a hemoglobin of almost 7 warrants or insurance to pay for weekly
blood tests.
If you're not getting a pain under insurance at all, and the doctor's charging more, you
can get those run through our lab store for probably less expensive, but just make sure you
send me the lab so that you have them done.